t
à Venise.
- Le producteur Roger Frappier
était fébrile à l'idée de
présenter à la Mostra de Venise
son film "Le pouvoir du chien".
ROGER FRAPPIER, Co-producteur
du film "The Power of the dog"
- c'est un rêve devenu réalité.
C'est vraiment une journée
mémorable pour moi.
- "Le pouvoir du chien" est
une adaptation du roman
de l'écrivain américain
Thomas Savage paru en 1967.
Le récit se passe en 1925
au Montana, Phil, un
propriétaire de ranch,
mène la vie dure à
la nouvelle épouse de son frère.
Roger Frappier a eu l'idée il y
a huit ans d'acheter les droits
cinématographique du livre.
- C'est un très grand roman,
méconnu, mais un très grand
roman que j'ai trouvé par hasard
dans ma chambre d'hôtel à Paris
par une nuit d'insomnie avec
lequel je suis complètement
tombé en amour. Ça m'a pris une
année demie pour obtenir
les droits mais je savais que
c'était moi qui étais pour faire
ce film.
- Le livre habitait aussi
la réalisatrice, Jane Campion.
la première femme à avoir
remporté la Palme d'Or
au Festival de Cannes avec
son film "La leçon de piano",
sorti en 1993. Pour "Le pouvoir
du chien", elle fait un retour
derrière la caméra après
une absence de douze ans avec
un film féministe.
JANE CAMPION, Réalisatrice,
film "The Power of the Dog "
- Le film met en vedette
Benedict Cumberbatch
et l'actrice Kristen Dunst,
que nous avons rencontrée
à la Mostra.
KRISTEN DUNST, Actrice dans
le film "The Power of the Dog"
"Le pouvoir du chien" est
distribué par le géant Netflix
qui espère se retrouver
à la cérémonie des Oscars
avec ce film.
- "Netflix nous a dit, surtout à
Jane que pour eux,
"The Power of the Dog" c'est
comme "Roma" de Cuaron.
- Après le tapis rouge à Venise,
l'embargo critique a été levée
sur le film "Le pouvoir du
chien" après l'avoir vu, ce que
je peux vous dire que c'est
qu'il s'agit d'un grand film
de Jane Campion, un film très
poétique, rempli de métaphores,
un film profond, aussi profond
que la plaie dans
la main du cowboy Phil.
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, V